a Florida law is under new scrutiny
after a six-year-old was involuntarily
committed to a mental health facility
following an incident at school the
girl's mother is now questioning the
wisdom of the Baker Act which allows
authorities to force a psychiatric
evaluation on anyone considered to be a
danger to themselves or others including
kids Manuel Bojorquez spoke to the mom
he's in Jacksonville Florida Manny what
exactly happened here
well good morning according to a
sheriff's report the girl was acting
quote out of control and attacking staff
members at her elementary school the
girl's mother who says the child has
special needs does not believe she's
getting full answers from the county's
public schools I specifically placed my
daughter at this school back in August
of 2019 because I was told that they had
specifically trained staff to handle
special needs children Martina Falk says
her six-year-old daughter Nadia has
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
and a mood disorder surrounded by her
legal team she told us her daughter's
nearly 2-day mandatory stay at a mental
health center away from her mother did
more harm than good she's traumatized
she is not herself anymore I don't know
what the long-term effects are it
happened here at Love Grove Elementary
in the sheriff's report a responding
social worker said the girl was a threat
to herself and others destroying school
property and attacking staff she was
removed from school and committed to a
Behavioral Health Center for psychiatric
evaluation under Florida's Baker Act why
would she Baker active why wasn't she
properly given the love and attention
that she needed dewfall County Schools
tell CBS News Baker Act decisions are
made by a third party licensed mental
health care professional and they say
we've reviewed the school's handling of
this situation and find it to be
compliant both with law and the best
interests of this student and all other
students at the school no you're not
going to an asylum in 2018 and KOCO
Florida this twelve-year-old boy with
autism was hauled off in a police
cruiser it was the boys first day in
middle school and during a meltdown he
scratched himself and then made a
suicidal reference that's when the
school resource officer acted the boys
mom Stacy Polanski says the school
should have called her before enforcing
the Baker Act the behavior plan outlined
what to do if he makes verbal threats
they only had to follow the plan the
number of children in voluntarily
transported to a mental health center in
Florida has more than doubled in the
last 15 years to about 36 thousand I
absolutely think that the Baker Act is
being overused this week Florida's
legislature is debating major reforms to
the nearly 50-year old law Jennifer
Webb's bill would require better
training for school officials and
resource officers and establish more
consistent rules on exactly when a
parent should be notified that their
child might be committed though it
should only be used as a last resort and
Baker acting six-year-olds just seems
excessive to me Webb believes that funds
allocated for schools after the high
school shooting in parkland could be
used for better training as for the
six-year-old girl in the case here in
Jacksonville her mother says she is
still looking for a different school for
her Anthony all right Manny thank you
boy you have to believe that the parents
should be notified I don't know enough
about the Baker Act to totally comment
on intelligently but it does seem to be
that they need to rethink a lot of
things associated with it six is young
for a mental health facility have yes
especially involuntarily